[MUSIC]
SPEAKER: John Locke, the
17th-century English philosopher,
argued that private property arose when
people mixed their labor with something
not yet owned by anyone else.
So if in the state of nature
I clear land in the wilderness
and grow crops there, I acquire a
right to the land and the crops.
It would be wrong for someone else
to take them away without my consent.
Let's see if Locke's idea helps us
think about a controversy that arises
each winter in Boston after snowstorms.
In Boston, many people park their
cars on the street near their homes.
It takes a long time to clear a parking
place from several feet of snow.
Imagine your frustration if after
spending hours digging out your car,
you drive to the
grocery store and return
to find another car parked
in the spot you dug out.
To prevent this, people who labor
to clear snow from parking spots
install markers, such as
traffic cones or lawn chairs,
to lay claim to them,
at least for a few days.
Should this be permitted?
Or should anyone be free to
use a public parking spot,
even if someone else has labored
long and hard to clear it?
[MUSIC]